i would not recommend going into  business with a romantic partner for  most people i think most people are just  not good at most things and most people  have really low levels of self-awareness  and are not good at picking partners or  spouses you got to get both right to  make the whole thing work if twice the  likelihood of it failing but i do think  that having a spouse as a partner is one  of those most magical things that's out  there because there is no trust like  having your partner be your spouse i  recommend it for those who have the  awareness to understand that you have to  have aligned mission of where you want  to go align values of how you want to  get there and similar interests in  day-to-day activities but complementary  skill sets and complementary  interpersonal dynamics that make all of  that work otherwise you get conflicts  you get disagreement you get people  overlapping people overstepping one  another which ultimately can lead things  to unravel